in the lush African greenery someone has
its eye on this cricket a chameleon
watches from a branch its eye turrets
give it a 360 degree view of its prey
check those blind spots blending in and
swaying like leaves on a branch it's
only a matter of time before it catches
something though only a matter of time
we'll just wait here now this is great
people's attention span on the
Internet's really long these days I'm
sorry that was mean the chameleons tail
acts as stabilization as it inches
towards the cricket gotta love the
hesitant chameleons it only needs to be
one body length away from the cricket
its tongue will do the rest of the work
still waiting suddenly the chameleon
launches its tongue at its target
finally its suction cup tipped tip
latches on to the cricket success we
made it
and suction-cupped tip yeah I mean can
any of you say it's suction-cupped tip
latches on to this I can't I can't I
literally cannot say it I cannot say it
it can't be done
[Music]
you